Decided to go with seven weeks of radiation five days a week and low-dose
chemosis planted once a week. They told me H.P.W. related squamous
I'll respond well to this treatment later. My genetic tape test came back with a
P-16 marker. I will also have a feeding tube and they're requesting Kate Farms
formula. So Kate Farms formula for feeding tubes way better than anything else
out there on the market. So that's good. My question is what kind of supplements
should I make sure to have a hand to comb at the short-term side effects of both
ulcers, dry mouth and skin irritation.
The one thing that I would take is that product that I talked to about before. I
think it's called clear so landy plus I think that's what it's called. You'd call
negative in the office that's our private label of preferred premier or excuse me
professional health products product of sletty of the thyroid. So that would be
the one that I would take that will help protect your thyroid that could help
protect some issues with the radiation. The dry mouth I'd be switching with
coconut oil and skin irritation. They do have a cream that they will give you. Some
people have also used just coconut oil on that. You could put a little bit of
essential oil in that as well like frankincense. Anything that could keep my
throat from swelling anytime you think of swelling in pain you go back to those
flavonoids that we've talked about so often. UGCG, curcumin, boscwellia,
resveratrol, stiggy, dental, white willow bark, those are the things. A lot of
those are in our product called clear inflame or the AI product has that in
there. Those things are there too. The clear inflame is probably a little bit
cleaner specifically for this. We'll also conjure it about long-term effects
difficulty swallowing the taste changes. Taste changes are going to be hard to get
around because there's damage with radiation to your taste buds. The difficulty
swallowing it would just be going back to the slab or the heart. I think you might
want to think of two if you ever travel swallowing pills as the liposomal curcumin
can be really helpful. That can be helpful. The product gland supplement
help with that. The product gland supplement will help just protect the
product gland and help with production of saliva so that's what that will
help with which was going to help many of those things especially the